es ist eine sehr gute idee jetzt mit
dieser ersten gruppe anzufangen das
heißt die über 80-jährigen und natürlich
menschen die medizinischen bereich tätig
sind
aber wir haben ja eine nationale in
fraktion vor uns und da zählt doch auch
mindestmaß an geschwindigkeit und ich
hatte erwartet
doch dass man innerhalb von 90 tagen
also dann tatsächlich 80 millionen
deutsche durch schimpfen würde um sich
an den usa arbeiten versprechend ist 100
millionen amerikaner in 100 tagen das
was der sparplan sozusagen vorsieht ist
dass wir nicht mal bis ende des jahres
mit den impfungen doors sind ich denke
dass es der bevölkerung nicht zuzumuten
wenn wir nicht bis zu den sommerferien
alle geben das heißt es gibt viel zu
wenig ressourcen man steckt zu wenig
geld herein und natürlich hätte man viel
viel mehr impfdosen bestellen müssen das
ist ja insgesamt doch seit märz bekannt
dass die aufgabe kommt und die israelis
die impfen die sind im juni fertig und
wir werden von der größten gruppe der
bevölkerung die in dieser
prioritätenliste stehe
das sind nämlich die unter 60-jährigen
das sind die die auch die wirtschaft am
laufen halten von denen wird erwartet
dass sie dann erst im herbst rankommen
das wird so niemals über die bühne gehen
können
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren